可能这个要求是很过分的，
他没有想过，
他狮子大张嘴要的这个彩礼，
可能毁掉你一辈子的幸干，
可能把你爱的男人给吓跑了，
可能让你陷入一种一辈子很难再反转的这样一个余地，
他们没有考虑过这一点，
我的理解是既然他们没有考虑我，
那我为什么还要再去考虑他们呢？
我想跟您咨询一下关于结婚和彩礼的问题，
我是江西人，
29岁，
在广东体这里工作，
我有一个因为脑瘫生活不能自理的弟弟，
还有两个姐姐已经结婚了，
我是研究生，
父母可能因为基于以上原因呢，
就我结婚提出了比较高的彩礼，
他们列了一张清单，
杂七杂八，
男方那边要出36万多，
这还不包括男方要出的彩礼，
那我个人比较独立，
我在珠三角地区，
自己有一套贷款的房子，
男方是南京的独生子，
也是研究生，
为我来深圳了，
他家条件比我好，
现在我们感情稳定，
准备结婚，
但被我家里的这一张巨高额的这个清单卡住了，
现在不知道怎么处理，
那我有以下几个问题，
第一个是关于我父母的要求，
面对我家里这个比较过分的清单，
我是否应该继续和他们谈判，
还是说可以自己做决定，
以后凭自己能力再补贴我的父母？
法律上我对我的父母和弟弟到底有多少责任。
第二个就是关。
基于婚礼和沟通，
我的男朋友家可能想要完整的婚礼，
但是由于我自己家里情况特殊，
我不想让双方父母过多的接触，
我该怎么和男朋友家里沟通，
让他们理解并接受简化的仪式，
最好是双方父母不要，
尽量一切从简刷天这两个问题父母确实有点过分啊，
从做父母的角度，
多要一点彩礼去帮助一个脑瘫的儿子呢？
可能也没有干什么伤天害理的事儿，
也没有什么十恶不赦，
但是从你的角度来看的话，
你父母的这个要求是很过分的，
他没有想过他师父大张嘴要的这个彩礼可能毁掉你一辈子的幸干，
可能把你爱的男人给吓跑了，
是吧，
可能让你陷入一种一辈子很难再寰转的这样一个余地，
他们没有考虑过这一点，
我的理解是，
既然他们没有考虑我，
那我为什么还要再去考虑他们呢？
我理解的点的话，
可能就会比较绝吧，
我会所有的彩礼我自己收着，
然后婚礼的话，
我就是强势，
我就是强简化的伴，
不用男方的亲戚，
我这边最多出个伴娘，
其他都不用参加。
至于说你对你父母的责任，
你对你父母的责任是平摊在3个姐妹身上的，
就是以后你父母如果说没有退休金，
没有养老金，
没有生活来源，
经济比较困难，
那么你对父母的责任是平摊在3个健康的姐姐身上的，
承担那3个。
之一就可以了，
然后对你弟弟的责任，
坦率的说啊，
只要你父母健在的话，
你对弟弟没有责任，
你对弟弟没有抚养的义务，
但如果说真的有一天父母不在了，
那这弟弟也是你们3个姐妹共同来分摊，
前提条件是你有这个能力，
你有能力的情况下才有责任，
当然你确实有这个能力啊，
那也是3个姐妹来分摊。
主要现在的问题就是我确实是想要解会一切的流程的仪式，
但是我不知道怎么样去和我父母沟通，
他现在把这张单列给我了，
我是没有回复她的，
我也没有把这个信息传递给男朋友，
不需要沟通，
你该积极该办婚礼去南方办就去南方办，
该领结婚证就领结婚证，
首先第一点啊，
你该要彩礼是先要到你的卡里了，
其次办婚礼的话，
就是按照男方的习俗，
男方怎么要求我怎么配合，
我只是不出我父母，
我跟男方好解释啊，
我们家乡就是这种风俗，
就是男方办婚礼的时候就出个女方就可以了，
等到我们女方办婚礼的时候出个男方就可以了，
很好解释啊，
我们家都是个传统，
我几个姐姐都这么过来的，
可能他们之前也多少有一点了解，
江西的彩礼也被吓到了，
所以现在也想看看我们这边的这个风，
一切自己做主，
和我男朋友就是去协商这个金额，
就是我自己心里做了个主，
比如说我自己想要拿到拿20万彩礼打到我的账。
然后我自己做存起来放在一张卡里，
作为我的婚前财产，
作为育儿基金，
这个是可以的，
你就这么说啊，
你也知道我们江西的彩礼是非常重的，
如果说这个钱打到我爸妈那里的话，
可能我爸妈就要用来帮助我的弟弟，
那从我们现有的条件来说的话，
我觉得我们不具备这样的条件，
而且的话我也有私心，
我想跟你好好过日子，
我们才是一家人，
我不愿意这个钱打到我爸妈的手里去，
如果说这个钱假设按照我们江西的习俗的话，
可能是38万，
甚至可能是48万，
我觉得这个对于我们两口子来说的话，
可能现在我们也没有这样的条件，
而且我也不愿意让你的家庭承担这么高的费用和负担，
我折中一下，
我觉得我就要个20万，
你打到我的卡里就可以了，
坦诚的跟我男朋友说啊，
而且这个钱我们也是以后要花到家庭里头的，
以后养育孩子呀，
家里面的建设也是要花到我们自己两口子家里头的，
那都他那么说呀，
那我在跟我男朋友和他家里人谈平衡的事情的时候，
就以我自己的意见为准，
一切不与父母商量，
对，
至于以后说你条件特别好，
以自己的家庭建设，
有富裕，
有这个余粮，
有这个余力，
可以帮衬帮衬父母也好，
弟弟也好，
那个时候心态不一样，
那个时候我不是被逼的，
我不是被你们现在卡着我结婚的事儿，
卡着这个彩礼的这个。
节点来逼我的，
对不对？
嗯，
他们给我列了一个36万的清单，
而且不包括彩礼，
不给任何嫁妆，
他说如果你要嫁妆的话，
你还得以36万往上加，
你要跑多少你就加多少，
他们现在卡着这个，
然后呢，
又怕我跑，
又有一点想松口，
但是那意思就是我现在不需要再跟他们有任何的谈判了，
只加上我自己心里的想法，
什么都不愿跟他们谈了。
我要是你的话，
我更绝，
我说男方不同意，
谎了，
我自己悄悄结婚，
他们谁知道我不发朋友圈，
谁知道听我大概明白，
谢谢，
好，
你就这样啊，
我就喜欢这种拎得清，
听劝有主见，
而且呢，
实际上这么干的姑娘，
这样的女生值得一辈子过好日子，
我要是一姑要的话，
我就跟我爸妈说，
我说分手了，
你一听这彩礼吓跑了她妈妈来闹怎么办？
有什么好闹的，
闹我怕什么，
现在我自己有工作，
我自己只能挣钱养活自己，
你们这些女孩子日子过好了之后，
都给我悄悄的，
朋友圈的不要发，
各种炫耀的不要发，
不要告诉别人你日子过多好，
你就是悄悄的过好日子就完事儿了。
在你有这个能力的时候，
有富裕的钱的时候，
有余粮的时候，
有持续的经济能力的时候，
你想要帮衬帮衬抚养的恩情也好，
兄弟姊妹之间的这个亲情也好，
你要帮衬帮衬可以，
刚能还有个人呢，
就发气死他。
你看你，
你就不听劝，
你给自己找麻烦，
记得点赞关注哦。